Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
This beautiful scene is from our paper by
the name Gaussian Material Synthesis, and
it contains more than a 100 different materials,
each of which has been learned and synthesized
by an AI.
None of these daisies and dandelions are alike,
each of them have a different material model.
Normally, to obtain results like this, an
artist has to engage in a direct interaction
with an interface that you see here.
This contains a ton of parameters and to be
able to use it properly the artist needs to
have years of experience in photorealistic
rendering and material modeling.
But, unfortunately, the problem gets even
worse.
Since a proper light simulation program needs
to create an image with the new material parameters,
this initially results in a noisy image that
typically takes 40 to 60 seconds to clear
up.
We have to wait out this 40 to 60 seconds
for every single parameter change that we
make.
This would take several hours in practical
use cases.
The goal of this project was to speed up workflows
like this by teaching an AI the concept of
material models such as metals, minerals and
translucent materials.
With our technique, first, we show the user
a gallery of random materials, who assigns
a score to each of them saying that I liked
this one, I didn't like that one, and get
an AI to learn our preferences and recommend
new materials for us.
We also created a neural renderer that replaces
the light simulation program and creates a
near-perfect image of the output in about
4 milliseconds.
That’s not real time, that’s ten times
faster than real time!
That is very fast and accurate.
However, our neural renderer is limited to
this scene that you see here.
So, the question is, is it possible to create
something that is a little more general?
Well, let’s have a look at this new work
that performs something similar that they
call differentiable rendering.
The problem formulation is the following:
we specify a target image that is either rendered
by a computer program, or even better, a photo.
The input is a pitiful approximation of it,
and now, hold on to your papers, because it
progressively changes the input materials,
textures, and even the geometry to match this
photo.
My goodness, even the geometry!
This thing is doing three people’s jobs
when given a target photo.
And you haven’t seen the best part here,
because there is an animation that shows how
the input evolves over time as we run this
technique.
As we start out, it almost immediately matches
the material properties and the base shape,
and after that, it refines the geometry to
make sure that the more intricate details
are also matched properly.
As always, some limitations apply, for instance,
area light sources are fine, but it doesn’t
support point light sources, may show problems
in the presence of discontinuities and mirror-like
materials.
I cannot wait to see where this ends up a
couple papers down the line and I really hope
this thing takes off - in my opinion, this
is one of the most refreshing and exciting
ideas in photorealistic rendering research
as of late.
More differentiable rendering papers please!
I would like to stress that there are also
other works on differentiable rendering.
This is not the first one.
However, if you have a closer look at the
paper in the description, you will see that
it does it better than previous techniques.
In this series, I try to make you feel how
I feel when I read these papers, and I hope
I have managed this time, but you be the judge,
please let me know in the comments!
And if this got you excited to learn more
about light transport, I am holding a Master-level
course on it at the Technical University of
Vienna.
This course used to take place behind closed
doors, but I feel that the teachings shouldn't
only be available for the 20-30 people who
can afford a University education, but they
should be available for everyone.
So, we recorded the entirety of the course
and it is now available for everyone, free
of charge.
If you are interested, have a look at the
video description to watch them.
This episode has been supported by Weights
& Biases.
Weights & Biases provides tools to track your
experiments in your deep learning projects.
It can save you a ton of time and money in
these projects and is being used by OpenAI,
Toyota Research, Stanford and Berkeley.
In this tutorial, they show you how to visualize
your machine learning models, and how to choose
the best one with the help of their tools.
Make sure to visit them through wandb.com/papers
or just click the link in the video description
and you can get a free demo today.
Our thanks to Weights & Biases for helping
us make better videos for you.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!